it's not quite as as you see it
hey
if my you can't see most of you can't
see where my hands are
i said i can't do the foot bring them
forward because they're pinned at the
back i can't lift them up i can't go
into him i'm pretty much in we'll say a
bear hug
so this right hand
the right hand i'll just show you this
is going to make um in tai chi they it's
like a bird's beak
all right
it's a bird's beak so i'm going to put
all my fingers together
i'm now turning on my cheek
but i can't move him so i can't move it
a centimeter my buttock
turns as the bird beat turns i don't
know how many people can see it but if i
keep there it's starting to come out at
that time this hand needs to have crept
over to there so now it's keyhole
because i've got one hand on it now i
can make it come out i mustn't make it
come out until then
now this hand is going to come here and
if i had a can to cut
cut
him
that would do that and that's what i'd
end up
it's the same as the katadori one
i can do this one it doesn't matter
if i have a
an open hand let's go this way
if i have an open hand
it's difficult to turn it if i make a
bird's beak
it's
easier if it comes out before i've got
my hands closed
then it's not kion
and he can take his hand away
so
we've got another technique for that so
bird speak
turn
[Music]
it comes out too quick he takes his hand
away never mind
all right so there's always another
technique so if you find you mess up do
the uremi
bird speak
if you think about it let go
if you think about it
other hand
you perhaps didn't see that earlier
the camera were left so i can't lie i
didn't go like that
i actually went i said that thumb goes
over there and i was closing my hand up
because i know i was
all right
so all right so there's a piece more to
add to it the bird's beak
this is in in tai chi
you know you hit these points
on the person's body
we won't go into that don't like it
aren't we okay